Up until now, we have explored a variety of workflows for modifying the metahuman neutral pose.
Using the DNA calibration repository allows us to do a variety of other things which we will explore in the next course.
But for now, let's wrap up our course with some tips and resources for you to use as you continue your training with metahumans and Unreal Engine.
In this final section of our course, we will go over some tips and resources that you may find helpful when adding DNA calibration to your metahuman customization workflow.
We will take a look at the latest release of the DNA calibration repository and then review some resources that are related to the topics we covered in this course.
So let's jump back into Maya one last time and look at a script from the latest release of the DNA calibration repository that allows us to build a rig with textures.
Back inside of Maya, in the DNA calibration folder, you will find in the examples folder a script named DNAViewerBuildRigWithTextures.
This script allows users to generate a functional rig in Maya with applied textures.
The assets this uses are located in the data folder.
This script has already been configured to load the eta DNA file from the mh4 folder.
I have already assembled eta with Oliver Textures.
To use this script, ensure that DirectX11 has been enabled.
To do this, go to Preferences, Display, and then to Viewport 2.0 and ensure the rendering engine is set to DirectX11.
In a new Python window, with the entire script pasted in here, ensure that you have assigned the path for the root directory pointing to the DNA calibration folder.
If you wish to use this with your own character, scroll down here and assign the paths for the DNA file and the maps folder.
Then select this entire script and execute it.
Now, let's review these steps before we move on.
The latest update of the DNA calibration repository includes support for Maya 2024 and the DNAViewerBuildRigWithTextures script located in the examples folder.
This script allows users to generate a functional rig with applied textures.
In Maya, ensure that DirectX11 is enabled.
To do this, go to Preferences, Display, Viewport 2.0, and select DirectX11.
In the script editor, paste the entire script in a new Python window.
Assign the root directory to point to the DNA calibration folder and then execute the entire script.
This will load a fully functional rig with textures.
Now, let's finish off with some resources for you to use.
All of the online resources and links to some of the tools discussed today can be found by following the URLs on this slide.
Feel free to pause here or take a screenshot for later reference.
You will find the links to the DNA calibration repository on GitHub, the Mesh to MetaHuman tutorial on the Unreal Engine YouTube channel,
the UnrealFest 2022 scan and texture-based workflow presentation, and the 2023 DNA calibration deep dive presentation.
This brings us to the end of the MetaHuman fitting and DNA calibration course.
In the next course, we will continue by exploring more advanced use cases using the DNA calibration library.
We will also go through the steps of bringing the modified assets back into Unreal Engine in order to finalize the changes of our MetaHuman characters.
I want to thank you for spending your time with me, and I hope that these videos help you as you continue working with MetaHumans in Unreal Engine.
Thank you for watching.